- Good morning Believe Nation
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
worlds major problems.
So to help on your journey today's message
is think outside the box.
Over to you Conor McGregor.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Every gym I went to it was
always they had their set way.
Every gym had their set
way of doing things.
Don't do it this way, do it that way.
So, that was just a normal
thing that I thought
just people just had their own set way
and you must do it that way.
You must stand this way,
you must kick this way,
you must punch this way.
But with John, when I went to John,
and I met my coach John Kavanagh,
at Straight Blast Gym,
it wasn't like that.
He had a more open mind and he encouraged
different movements and I
never experienced that before,
I never heard a coach
say that to me before.
And that stuck in my head
and I talked to myself,
you know this guy is
thinking outside the box,
you know what I mean, that he has a vision
that everything works and
he encourages every movement
because ultimately there is a time
and a place for every single move.
So I just knew when I met
John and when he spoke
it made complete sense
to me and that was it,
I stuck with him and he stuck with me
and the rest is history.
- So here's the easiest way I know of
to think outside the box.
A lot of people think you have to be
a creative genius, you
have to be artistic,
you have to think a certain way
to think outside the box, you don't.
Anybody can think outside the box.
For me, the easiest way to do it
is just take something
from another industry
that you also love and
bring it to your market.
This is where if you combine
the genius of the aim,
if you embrace the
things that make you you,
that's where you win
that nobody else can win
because you have all sorts
of different interests.
That if you narrow down and you only pick
one thing that you're going to focus on,
this is the only thing you're going to do,
one you're going to feel left out
because there's all these other interests
that you have and two
you're going to get stopped
because the people who love
that thing more than you
are going to go crush you,
where if you can combine
all these things down
into one, you embrace
everything that you love and find a way
to mix it up into a pot,
people can't replicate you.
You're unique, you have a unique voice,
you have a unique approach,
people can't just copy you.
The best they're ever going to
be is a junior version of you.
And so you think outside the box
by taking all these different interests
and taking something that's
worked in something else
and bring it to the thing you're doing
and people now will suddenly say that
you are a creative genius,
that you're so great
thinking outside the box,
but all you're really doing
is just pulling from different industries.
And this worked over and over and
over and over and over again.
I looked at Starbucks,
I love Howard Schultz,
he's on the wall in my office,
he got the idea for Starbucks
when he went on a trip to Milan.
He went to Italy and he
saw that the coffee shops
were the center of life in
Italy, and had been for decades.
That was the third home,
they had their office,
they had their home and then
they had the coffee shop
where people would hang
out, be a meeting place.
And he looked at North America
and he saw the Dunkin'
Donuts of the world,
where you just come in
and out, grab a coffee.
It's more utility and he wanted to create
that same third home
vibe in North America.
It worked in Italy for decades,
let's just bring it to
North America and boom,
one of the biggest brains
in the world was born.
Not because Howard's
necessarily a creative genius,
but because he borrowed
from other industries
and brought it to his own.
You look at this YouTube channel.
There's a couple things
that I brought here
from other industries that
have helped my channel grow.
I have a salsa business, I was a salsa DJ.
Part of DJing is taking
lots of different songs
and mixing them up in a way that
makes sense for a dance party.
I do that for a lot of my top 10's
and for a lot of the videos that I do.
I pull together different
clips that I feel
work well together and we make it
into an experience for you guys to enjoy.
Nobody else was doing that and definitely
in a business context, an
entrepreneurship context
on YouTube and it's helped me win.
I also approached YouTube as a business,
I'm an entrepreneur.
The idea that I want
to respond to everybody
who leaves a comment and I've hired people
on my team and might need
to hire somebody else
'cause you guys are commenting so quickly
that we're falling behind a little bit.
I want everybody to have
a response on a comment.
When somebody leaves a comment,
I want to respond to them.
I think it's important, I think
it's just part of business.
If somebody calls your store or walks
into your front door, you're
going to talk to them,
you're going to thank them,
you're going to acknowledge them.
And at the beginning of
a lot of YouTube channels
creators will respond to every comment,
they say I respond to every comment,
and it's easy because you
have one comment a day
or ten comments a day, it's not that hard
to respond to every comment.
But when you're getting two, three, 400
comments a day, let's
see if you can keep up.
And so they can't and
so they just drop it.
Where my approach is no,
you don't just drop it,
it's still important, you just
bring on people to help you.
You don't have to do
everything in your business.
Just like in the real business world,
I keep knocking my books over.
When you go in the real business world,
you start off doing everything yourself
and then you bring on a team to help you
and you move up and you
start focusing on things
that you're really, really,
really, really good at.
And so taking that
approach will bring you to
my YouTube channel,
where still most creators
of my size are not responding
to most of the comments.
Right, they may respond to a couple,
and then they just leave it,
where I love Believe Nation,
I love to communicate,
I thinks it's important
that you guys are
connecting and getting along
and there's a vibrant discussion.
And so I want to make
sure there's recognition
and acknowledgement so I
hire people to help me.
And so I talked to the guys at YouTube
with my account manager and he said wow,
that's such an outside the box idea.
It's not that outside the box,
it's not that creative it's just taking
something that works in business
and bringing it to YouTube.
And so you don't need to be
an insanely creative person.
You don't need to be the wild character
who's always thinking outside the box.
The way to do it is to take other things
that you're passionate
about, if you love baseball,
or you love Celine Dion
or you love beavers
or you love grocery
stores or you love cars,
whatever it is, your various
interests, you love the smurfs.
You know whatever it
is, find out something
that works there in that
community, in that business model
and just bring it to what
you're currently doing.
And if it's different and
it makes you stand out,
people will suddenly tout you as the next
creative genius and
outside the box thinker.
So the question today is I'm curious
what is one of the more
outside the box ideas
that you've had, that you've pulled from
a different industry and
applied to your business?
Really curious to find out,
leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a
quick shout to Gary Wilson.
Gary thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One
Word, I really appreciate
the support Gary and I
hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(typewriter sound)
- My thinking is so
superior and my knowledge
is so positive and my logic is so wise
until it clashes with the mentality
which is down here and I'm up there.
(audience laughs)
So by me being so high I can see more
and see farther than
you and you're looking
up at me and saying Ali
don't do it, don't do it.
(audience laughs)
Ali please stop before you get hurt.
And you're on a job making
60 or 70 pounds a week
and whoever does that is,
(audience laughs)
never been out of the country,
not known in his own neighborhood,
Ali don't do it, but I'm
at such a high level,
until I don't think like
you, I'm not like you.
I know I say you, I mean
the ordinary person.
- But you know why they say that?
I mean it's for the best
possible reasons though.
- They fear and they are worried,
looks dangerous to them.
- [Man] That's right.
- But it's not really
that dangerous to me.
- Don't let expertise silence you.
Work to find new
solutions to old problems.
Think outside of the
parameters that restrict
other people's thoughts.
Just because you're a novice on the job,
just because you haven't
faced the same challenges,
climbed the same cliffs,
doesn't mean that you can't contribute
to solutions in very significant ways.
When you're chided for your naviete,
and you will be, remind
your critics that a amateur
built the ark, experts built the titanic.
- Man statistics said if I did that
and I stopped going to
school and that's all I did
was hang in the hood that
I wasn't gon be here today.
So that's why I still
hang with the same people
that I was with back in the
hood and I changed my mentality.
I don't think the same way
I was when I was there.
I opened my mind up, I thought broader,
I thought outside of my horizons,
like you got to think outside the box
because that's the only
way you gon get out.
And when you trapped in the trap,
you really mentally trapped in a trap.
And it's me, like man, I
want to make sure my people
just know that that's just
not the end of your life.
If somebody tell you these statistics,
this not you, you gon fight statistics
and go the next level like, statistics
said I wouldn't even be here
talking to you right now
if I would have listened
to them and tell them
how my life would have been.
They say one out of 10
people, they gon be like this
or nine out of 10 black
males if they do this,
live this way, they gon do this,
you know what I'm saying,
it's no way around it.
They gon tell you it's no way around.
So if you in the hood right now,
you standing on the block everyday,
them police just riding by, that old lady
that's looking at you, that's
calling the police on you,
(man laughs)
the people who riding
by just looking at you
like they ain't nothing,
your pants sagging,
they think you ain't gon never be nothing,
they think you gon be like that
for the rest of your life.
Who is the person to tell you?
- [Man] You got to prove 'em wrong.
- That you gon be standing
on this block all your life.
It supposed to be a point in your life
where you only be here,
you give yourself a year or two.
You from here, it don't do no good
for you to be here all your life
and you spending the
majority of your life,
22 hours out your day trying to prove
you the hardest in the hood.
You come from this, you was born in this.
When you came home from the hospital,
you went to the hood,
you know what I'm saying.
So you done lived your whole life this way
for all your life, you deserve to live
in different neighborhood,
to better yourself
for three, four years
out of your whole life
when you been living this way.
Probably some dudes been living that way
for 20 years, 23 years, been in the hood
since they came home from the hospital
and they still trying to prove to the hood
how hard they is and
they end up not making it
because they didn't prove to they self.
You got to to yourself that you want more
than what the hood have to offer.